[Music]
millions of people take flights across
the globe each and every day maybe even
you are a frequent flier yourself
airplanes have been cleverly designed to
mimic normal conditions on the surface
of the earth as accurately as they can
but they're not perfect have you ever
wondered exactly what happens to your
body when you fly make sure you watch to
the end to learn about why flying can be
like getting an x-ray if this is your
first time visiting our channel please
give this video a big thumbs up and hit
that subscribe button for more cool
videos today we're showing you what
happens to your body on an airplane your
senses are dulled if you think that
airplane food tastes bland and
unappetizing you're not the only one and
the airlines aren't exactly the ones to
blame for this either in fact it's
really all down to your own biology did
you know that your senses of taste and
smell are dulled significantly once you
reach cruising altitude your ability to
taste saltiness and sweetness can
diminish by as much as 30% when you're
up in the air there are a number of
factors playing into this phenomenon
first the extremely dry cabin can
evaporate the mucus in your nasal
cavities decreasing your olfactory
perception your ability to taste is
linked to smell with some scientists
suggesting that 80% of what you taste
comes from your sense of smell to make
matters worse the pressurization of the
cabin also desensitizes your taste buds
interestingly enough even the low murmur
of a humming engine generates a
distracting white noise that has been
demonstrated to impact your ability to
taste these three factors combined
mercilessly to rob you of your sense of
taste leaving a great challenge for
airline catering services when providing
you with your in-flight meal there is a
bright side though bitter sour and umami
also known as savory flavors aren't as
affected by these factors so you can
always opt for the classic tomato juice
if you want to enjoy a potent flavor you
become dehydrated that dry cabin air
does more than just affect your ability
to smell at 30,000 feet in the air
cabin humidity levels reach a meager 12
percent which also happens to be drier
than a desert this leaves your body
extremely dehydrated and this
dehydration presents itself in many ways
beyond just feeling thirsty your body is
comfortable dealing with air at
approximately 50% humidity when the
cabin air is almost five times as dry as
that threshold the effects of
dehydration act to wrap
and without clemency you will very
quickly feel thirsty which presents a
dilemma if you're as uncomfortable using
an airplane lavatory as we are either
hydrate often and face the bathroom
frequently potentially disturbing your
aisle seat neighbor or risk the effects
of dehydration your eyes will dry up
your skin will feel reptilian and the
mucus protecting your sinuses nostrils
and throat will evaporate leaving you
more prone to infection
this lack of hydration can give you a
headache make you dizzy and even
increase your heart rate or lower your
blood pressure in extreme instances make
sure you have plenty of lotion and don't
be shy to drink water even if it means
frequent bathroom breaks the
consequences of dehydration simply
aren't worth it avoid alcohol coffee and
tea while you're at it which possess
diuretic properties and can leave you
even more dehydrated you're more likely
to get sick like we mentioned earlier
evaporated mucus in your throat and
sinuses can leave you more vulnerable to
falling ill but that's not the only
reason why you're more likely to get
sick while on an airplane imagine it now
300 people crammed in a metal can in the
sky for several hours sure the air is
recycled fairly well but all it takes is
a few people coughing or sneezing around
you before the whole cabin has a cold it
comes as no surprise then that research
suggests you're 100 times more likely to
catch a cold while on an airplane than
on any given day on the ground
the virus is responsible for causing
colds and respiratory infections also
happen to thrive very well in dry
conditions meaning you're significantly
more vulnerable to airborne sickness
even a small number of cases have popped
up in which people cut severe illnesses
such as tuberculosis from being cooped
up in the cabin of an airplane we
haven't even told you yet about the
cleanliness of your seat and tray table
and even the water you drink to keep you
hydrated unfriendly bacteria such as
ecoli and golden staph have been known
to live on your seats upholstery and
your tray table for as long as a week
and if you think airplane cleanings
happen frequently enough to avoid that
you'd be wrong even the sides of the
drinking water tank have been found to
contain traces of e.coli your brain gets
confused there are a number of reasons
your brain starts to get confused on a
flight perhaps the most well-known
example is jet lag jet lag can affect
your physical response to the world
because your cortisol levels your normal
circadian rhythm goes with the
light-dark cycle of night and day your
body produces
cortisol the stress hormone at specific
times of the day leading you to feel
tired when they're low or more alert
when they're high jumping several time
zones can really affect this hi-low
process and if you need to be alert and
you have low cortisol levels your entire
body suffers for it you feel tired your
heart rate isn't regulated properly and
your brain doesn't know what time it is
because it's still stuck in your origin
time zone in addition to this jetlag the
whole process of moving without it being
visually obvious that you're moving
really confuses your brain your inner
ear is responsible for your sense of
balance it can also detect a motion when
your ears are telling your brain that
you're moving but your eyes tell it that
you're stationary you can suffer from
motion sickness these two conflicting
senses can make for an extremely
uncomfortable flight especially if
you're particularly sensitive to the
side effects of motion sickness you get
a headache your poor head can't catch a
break on the plane in addition to
confusion about the time of day and
whether or not you're moving you are
also at a higher risk of suffering from
an airplane headache this type of
headache is rather strange given that it
usually doesn't last for very long it
mostly affects men and it's onset
usually occurs during landing
researchers suggest that this headache
comes on due to a discrepancy between
the pressure of the airplane cabin and
the pressure of the frontal sinuses for
some people this difference occurs
likely because some bodies have trouble
equalizing the pressure increase that
transpires when landing even if you're
not a victim on this landing headache
you might still be at risk of developing
a headache mid-flight if you aren't
hydrating properly during your flight
you risk acquiring a dehydration
headache water is necessary to balance
the functions in the body if your body
doesn't have enough of it the brain can
contract due to lack of fluid when this
happens you're shrunken brain ends up
pulling away from the skull causing the
unpleasant pressure that most people
know to be a headache interestingly this
is also probably why people experience
head pain when they wake up after a
night out drinking don't forget to stay
hydrated your ears pop and your teeth
hurt we're willing to bet that you
already know about popping ears on
planes you've probably experienced it
yourself but do you know why it happens
if you guess that it has to do with
cabin pressure you'd be correct cabin
pressure affects a wide array of bodily
functions if you haven't noticed as you
take off from the runway the air
pressure in the cabin decreases if you
remember your high school chemistry
there is a law called Boyle's law that
states that gas pressure and volume are
in
firstly related meaning that as one goes
up the other goes down thus as the
pressure in the cabin goes down the air
in your middle ear expands the popping
feeling is just what happens when the
pressure in your ear equalizes with that
of the cabin but did you know Boyle's
law can also affect your teeth yes if
you happen to have fillings or a cavity
the air in these tiny pockets in your
teeth can also increase in volume
otherwise known as expansion leading to
the unquestionably uncomfortable feeling
of an airplane toothache perhaps the
worst part of this ache is that unlike
ear popping there is little you can do
to relieve the discomfort everyone knows
to chew gum to speed up the pressure
equalization process in the ears but
your only real option for a toothache is
a topical or oral painkiller you
experience bloating Boyle's law strikes
again if you've ever fallen victim to
airplane bloating then you know where
we're going with this yes this bloating
is due to the lower air pressure in the
cabin well you're at cruising altitude
the gases in your body can expand as
much as 25% talk about gassy discomfort
this unfortunate side effect of low
pressure also happens to affect the gas
in your intestines unfortunately this
can lead to the unbearable urge to break
wind something we imagine you're not too
comfortable doing when confined in a
metal tube in the sky with 300 other
passengers it's really not good for the
body to hold an intestinal gas however
so it's best to find a way to pass it
peacefully without disturbing your
neighbors if you've been good about
hydration we're sure you'll be visiting
the lavatory anyway in the end everyone
is doing it and it's for your own good
it's probably also best to avoid foods
that can make you gassy before and
during your flight
this gas volume increase can also affect
more than just your gut you have gas
dissolved in the synovial fluid in your
joints the fluid can thicken and the gas
can expand putting more pressure on your
joints and causing more discomfort
especially for sufferers of arthritis
and other inflammatory joint pains your
legs and feet pull with blood we all
know that it's not fun sitting in a
cramped airplane seat for hours on end
but did you know that it's also
potentially dangerous especially for
long-haul flights which can be as long
as 17 hours it's really important to get
up and take a walk down the aisle to
keep your blood circulating through your
entire body when you sit for several
hours at a time without moving blood
tends to pool in your feet ankles and
lower legs this swelling can be
extremely uncomfortable for most
painful for some and downright dangerous
for a few who are at risk of a condition
known as deep vein thrombosis also
referred to as DVT this condition rears
its ugly head when a blood clot also
known as a thrombus forms in one of the
deep veins in your body the most common
place for this to happen is the legs and
symptoms can present themselves as pain
or swelling but sometimes do not appear
at all for people prone to issues with
blood clots it's especially important
that they take frequent walks up and
down the aisles of the plane they risk
the blood clot getting loose and
traveling to hazardous locations such as
the lungs where they can get stuck and
block the blood flow to these essential
organs don't be shy to move your health
is more important
you become oxygen deprived have you ever
visited a city at a higher altitude than
your own home if yes you might have
found that climbing even just a few
stairs can be a taxing endeavor
something similar happens on a plane at
higher altitudes the air pressure is
lower than it is at sea level and there
is less oxygen available in the air
airplane cabins are pressurized to about
75% of normal atmospheric pressure
simulating an altitude of around 6,000
to 8,000 feet above sea level this is
approximately equivalent to the
atmospheric pressure in Mexico City if
you're on a long-haul flight this lack
of oxygen can actually lead to a
condition called hypoxia characterized
by a deficiency of oxygen in parts or
all of the body this can contribute to a
number of unpleasant symptoms such as
headache dizziness and fatigue this
isn't to say the air isn't safe it's
just that most people aren't used to the
lower oxygen levels thus you can start
to become very sleepy not that it's easy
to fall asleep on a plane in the first
place additionally the most important
part of your body can become further
oxygen deprived for other reasons when
you're sitting in the same seat for
hours on end and not moving much your
blood flow decreases including blood
flow to the brain this leaves your brain
further hungry for oxygen reducing
mental sharpness it's not just the
stress of travel causing you to feel
bogged down you get blasted by radiation
did you know that flying at such high
altitude can put you more at risk to the
consequences of radiation from the Sun
the Sun gives off two forms of UV
radiation you
VA and UVB the planes windows are
capable of blocking UVB rays but the
more dangerous UVA rays are still able
to make it through one study found that
a seven hour plane ride can dish out as
much radiation as a standard x-ray would
to put that into perspective flying for
one hour at 30,000 feet is approximately
equivalent to spending 20 minutes in a
tanning bed of course you can always
just close the blinds on the window if
you happen to have a window seat
something that unfortunately our pilots
cannot do pilots have been known to have
higher incidences of skin cancer most
likely due to regularly sitting for many
hours on end at high altitudes with only
a window to protect them if your
frequent flyer and concerned about
exposure to UV radiation and it's
unforgiving consequences make sure to
take the sunscreen with you on your
future flights optionally if the thought
of applying sunscreen to take a flight
doesn't appeal to you you could also
just take a seat further away from the
windows it's important to keep that skin
young and healthy and that's all for
what happens to your body on an airplane
we hope you enjoyed our video and if you
did don't forget to check out 10 things
you should never do on an airplane for
more flying facts
[Music]